the best part everybody across all my
social platforms and the new Vayner
commerce platforms of Gary Vaynerchuk I
will introduce the wonderfully
attractive Robbie Diggs been freed and
Zubin and shortly however the best part
of this before we get into coffee and
commerce which is what we're calling
this real this week or two that I'm
gonna be doing original free content for
my podcast at my live platforms around
this incredibly exciting launch of
banner Commerce which we'll get to in a
second but by far the best thing was we
were just about to go live and and I was
on with Dustin who also produces tea
with Gary Vee with me and he said I'm
not gonna you know when I said are we
going line because yeah we're about to
go live he's like I'm not sure how
you're gonna know it's going live but
just start in ten seconds and then about
eight seconds in the top left corner of
my screen went from scheduled to live so
Dustin I don't know if you can jump in
here and say hello because I know a lot
of people from TV character Dustin that
was the way I was gonna know it was live
the corner I've never been on the other
side so I don't know it's a pretty good
indicator get back to your side okay bye
anyway hello everybody I see a lot of
the comments coming through just like I
do with tea with Gary Vee so this makes
it even more fun for everybody who's
listening as a podcast whether we're
doing that tomorrow a couple days later
thank you this is a very special day in
the history of a noir ex panorex if you
don't know is the holding company that
houses all these companies that I'm
building in the Vayner Empire as I like
to call it in my own head but the Vayner
conglomerate of businesses which starts
with vaynermedia decade ago and then and
then kind of grew from a scenario of the
acquisition we made of pure Wow calm
which started a publishing side which we
call the gallery media group which shows
homes and houses all those publishing
sides and then just an explosion of like
business intelligence SAS product tracer
tech the sacha group comm our small
business complement our our speaking
Bureau Vayner speakers and on and on and
on and we add another sister brother to
the equation today officially something
that I will let Robbie tell the origin
story of a little bit about Vayner
commerce and before before we get into
that big shout out to Sabir
an early executive at vaynermedia who
started the initial Vayner commerce
capability inside of vaynermedia before
we've taken get it out so before I want
any further I want to give you a big
shout out Sabir I hope you're watching
or hear this
you were enormously important part of
this journey along with many other
employees and so why don't we introduce
ourselves
Robby why don't you start yeah so on
Robby Deeks chief commercial officer in
commerce I've been with Boehner now for
about two years building towards you
know this day and previously came from
Shopify plus where I worked for two
years on the enterprise side you guys
been freedom the CTO at Vayner commerce
you want the life story you want the
30-second version 63 seconds all right
I've been into computers and technology
my entire life have started building
computer as well as 10 messing around
the internet when it kind of first came
about and ultimately started a business
when I was 13 building websites and an
e-commerce business selling custom old
computers which I'm sure as Gary can
attest to if you're doing EECOM in the
90s everyone thought you're a maniac
that's fine okay earned the title so yes
since then I kind of built a video
streaming news network platform in the
early 2000s catering to car enthusiasts
again I think with that early theme of
streaming HD videos right when people
first had a to the TVs in like 2002 so
that was called so early and kind of
spent my 20s bouncing around in the tech
startup world built the social shopping
platform and some other interesting
platforms like that and then seven years
ago Metin zoom in came to lucid fusion
we could spend four hours talking to all
the stuff we talked about seven years
but let's just say it is collated into
today which is the launch of a new
comers
absolutely great to be with all you
Jumma lobby
now president of major commerce
previously CEO of lucid fusion support
one
years as been mentioned pride event
joining kind of did everything in terms
of web development app development etc
for kind of any all kinds of companies
and then seven years ago decided hey we
need to bring in bolster our team used
to be been and the rest of the team and
then really focus on one area decided to
focus on e-commerce decided to partner
with Shopify plus and jump on that
bandwagon early and then I'll let Robbie
as Gary mentioned tell you the origin
story of how the three of us met
everything transformed from there
fantastic well you know since we are
live and I'm gonna incorporate some
comments Mika Ellis says I totally
admire what Gary has achieved he is such
an aspiring person nevertheless I can't
help whatever he speaks I get stressed
meek I'm sorry I don't want to stress
you I actually think it's super you know
I might be high-energy and intense but I
actually think it's patience and and
slow it down and and optimism so
hopefully you can you're here some
things here that do not stress you so
let's get right into this you know how
did this all happen you know why don't
we start with this you know Robbie why
don't you tell the story of the first
time we met and and what you thought I
know it's a very fun circumstance I know
the length is interesting let's just
play it out tell us the story of that I
think it's a we you know it's one of the
seeds at that point severe had been at
Bainer we were starting to do some
ecommerce for anybody who doesn't know
of inner commerce actually Zubin Robbie
how would you describe what Boehner
commerce does let's start there and then
we'll go to the origin story yes so
Vader commerce is a full funnel growth
engineering firm so we're focused on the
entire funnel acquisition conversion
retention etc across retail across
online and helping brands basically
navigate that path and find sustainable
growth across that whether its creative
its media its technology data Sciences
really connecting everything and
bolstering it Robbie I think I think you
been covered it pretty well but in terms
of in terms of I guess to connect what
you've been just mentioned and the first
meeting though there let me let me turn
what Zubin just said into English that
normal people can understand thank you
Boehner
builds commerce sites for people that
want to sell things makes them better
when somebody else built them if they're
all [ __ ] up and also and most
importantly we've lived through a huge
era where people have used Facebook and
Instagram and other media outlets to get
customers to your website and then they
buy something and you've got a business
the problem is most people don't have
their economics right they don't realize
how much money they're losing on
shipping they don't think about
packaging and messaging on the shipping
they don't realize that 4,000 landing
pages is better than one if their ads
match up and they have the ability to
produce that much content and creativity
even on the ads and content they don't
realize that a lot of variations of
creative will drive down your cack
customer acquisition cost we've assessed
space for a long time then and I've been
in a table but all of us have pretty
much been in our entire careers cuz even
since I've been running Vayner I've
always got one big eye on
winelibrary.com email marketing you know
CRM you know truly understanding the
cost of the media or the creative or
what's actually driving your business
and then truly thinking about lifetime
value no business take away e-commerce a
restaurant a farmer somebody's selling
stones 200 years ago if your whole
business was only based on having
somebody only shop with you once you've
got a fucked-up business so sustainable
strategies
so what fader Commerce does if you're
watching right now for the less than 1%
that might consider working with banner
Commerce there's a consulting side where
we literally look at your business sit
down for weeks come up with better ideas
tell you how to do it and then
potentially either do it for you on the
building out or doing stuff or you take
that and do it internally or you do it
with somebody else and then there's the
building and tech side where we build
things from you know day one like you're
ready to you've got you know some janky
system that wanted to prove out the
concept then you want to build on top of
you know a platform and so that's a that
that's what it does and so thinking and
doing at the macro so Robbie first story
yeah so a bit of background I was at
Shopify plus 2016-2017 sorry on the
enterprise side then went into a team
called new markets and that role was
interesting because it was that it was
sort of the peak or the
beginning of the peak of you know the
DDC marketing playbook a lot of venture
capital came in a lot of brands got
funded there's exits and what was
interesting was I sat in conversations
with executives with consultants with
investors and everyone was saying
basically the same thing everyone had
the same strategies they had the same
tech stack they had the same approaches
and so it started to become obvious that
everything was gonna be commoditized
outright that arbitrage that existed in
the early 2010's was gonna go away and
as brands are scaling on the platform on
Shopify plus you know to me I didn't see
who they had to turn to from which
strategic growth perspective and so that
sort of led to the the idea that there
be an opportunity for a new type of firm
in the e-commerce space but was
important and sort of time back to what
Zubin was talking about was all the
previous event firms and the firm's
existed a sort of focus on one area
right they might focus on creative they
might focus on technology with Vayner
that you do creative in media but no one
was sort of understanding the full
business nor were they getting exposure
to all those problems and so the the
idea was if you could actually build a
firm that understand complete holistic
growth and had exposure to all those
areas and had top talent in each of
those areas you could start actually you
know growing the businesses in much more
sustainable ways and effective ways and
what led me to the meeting with Hugh
Gary was I thought you were probably
obviously Vayner we had scale but you're
also the only crazy enough CEO that
could pull off operating all those
different functions and bringing them
together and changing the culture around
creating sustainable growth and so
obviously we had a mutual connection and
Alex DeSimone
Alex I tried to book you as a speaker in
Amsterdam like two years earlier through
Alex and he tried to sell me to many
Gary books so it didn't actually happen
but so he sounds like they were under
something you were trying to steal me on
some arbitrage [ __ ] yes yeah so you know
we essentially got that 10-minute
meeting in New York
in your office is that one more time for
the kids in the back ten minute meeting
so let's shoot straight here because
we've never had this talk let's make
this entertaining or at least
interesting or insightful or bring down
it in different ways when you see that
the meeting is ten minutes you think I'm
a dick face do you think I'm efficient
do you think like oh you start knowing
you a little bit did you start talking
about strategy like how did you did you
think that you were gonna schmooze your
way into 30 like how did you think about
that so right when I saw the 10 Alex
obviously set the expectations that it
was gonna even 10 minutes but I have
already known your persona and we're
both fast talkers so I actually felt
pretty pretty good about it yeah and and
you know going into the actual meeting
you know I basically articulated a lot
of what I just said and gave the context
on you know basically I thought the
market was heading to a place that
wasn't good and no one else was gonna
you know solve it and and I think it was
became obvious very early on was you've
been thinking about me calm probably for
the past 10 years and so you finished a
lot of the sentences and I think it was
around minute for that you kind of just
hired me and then and then it escalated
to you sort of talking about the empire
building and and all of that that was
that was the ten minutes and then that
was that you know I remember like was
our second meeting while I was filling
like planet of the apps or or sores yeah
Los Angeles yeah like I met you and like
like we literally had a meeting
c.b.c parking lot yeah okay so Zubin
pick up this story so Robbie and I start
jamming so Robbie calls me actually in
San Francisco I remember in September
17-18 2017 he calls me and I'm on my way
to a friend's wedding he calls me and
says hey and we'd met because we did a
number deals together Shopify plus most
notably the hundreds we worked on that
together and so Robbie Ben and I had met
in Waterloo Canada months before that
Ben and I did a lunch and learn with the
Tri team to explain like how we leverage
their technology extended it all the
stuff
and commerce had a great time over there
in Waterloo met Robbie and Robbie says
to me we're going to the airport the
next day Robbie says to me the night
before it can I get a ride with you to
Toronto and I said sure
now find out years later as you
mentioned Robbie being strategic
he actually planned that entire
conversation to tell me that he didn't
have a ride so he could ride with me and
we can chat so we start chatting have a
great conversation on Commerce tech all
this stuff we miss our exit
that was not planned and we missed our
exit it took us another 40 minutes to
reroute and in that 40 minutes we bonded
and that's realized okay [ __ ] there's
something special here what are we gonna
do about it
so come September that year he tells me
he's gonna go meet with you and says
look I'm thinking about different things
and I talked to Gary Vaynerchuk do you
know Gary Vaynerchuk is and I said yeah
I know of them I know of him he said I
want to see what opportunities there are
in New York and whatnot I said look if
it doesn't work out with Gary you call
me you're an amazing salesperson I'll
hire you so he calls me and a week later
and says had a great meeting with Gary
Gary's gonna come to LA in December and
he wants to meet you for breakfast and I
said brilliant I'd love to meet Gary and
he said Gary usually takes ten fifteen
minute meetings you're gonna get an hour
with him for breakfast which is like 10
minutes really 10 minutes of time is
easy putting an hour of time with Derek
what can we gonna do this but we hit it
off and we hit it off on a human level I
think it was really important for me to
understand kind of what you do what
vaynermedia does for a lot of people
that don't understand what you do at
vaynermedia or what the company does
Vayner acts they don't know the full
extent of your organization and you
frankly and so having that conversation
I'm gonna lining on so many different
actually something I think a lot about
yeah was it in that meeting you're like
oh this guy's not a mascot he's an
operator yes it was good it was beyond
an operator right it's like - Robbie's
point I think you meet different people
interact with different people there
people that position themselves as one
thing or another and they don't have
that depth and you have that
conversation and then again in like
10-15 minutes I'm like oh man I really
like this guy he actually gets it and
it's not just talk
and then I think you mentioned something
like that to me and then we realize like
there's a lot of alignment there and and
again people don't understand the
magnitude of the organization this is
that you built right many of the people
that are listening right now and and
that became abundantly clear to me in
like 15 20 minutes so I'm like okay this
is awesome how are we gonna like work
together I want to add some context that
- so I called him coming
so you went Gary in that 10 minute
meeting to like empire building and
there was actually when I was leaving
that meeting that I I was like [ __ ] what
am I gonna do you know I need to go
build this guy a big business now based
on that last 10 minutes and so and as
much as I love Zubin on a human level
and we did connect I also realized that
they were building something that Ben's
going to talk about in terms of how they
approach technology and how we saw the
market changing and so my first call was
to zoom in because I knew that they were
building something that was going to be
critical for you know what I thought was
all brands on the tech stack and how
they're building technology in just a
very different way on chop Fayed Plus
and then if you want to go into that a
bit and just sort of talk about it but
that that's kind of like in real time
what happens and then and then I think I
wrote you and know Gary saying hey we
need to buy this business and he
responded and said how much meeting then
before we get into what you build on top
cuz I'm reading the comments which is
the advantage of this podcast that I
don't normally have when I'm just doing
a podcast which making I never do a
podcast in my office again and only do
it this way you know talk to me about
the biggest mistake people make with
building out their website what is going
on with you know run-up Shopify a lot
Robbie comes from there we're all
advocates of it because you know the
open source nature of it there are
obviously other players Magento big
commerce things of that nature like what
are you seeing at like you know you know
listen obviously I want to do this
podcast cuz I want people to be aware
we're in the game
to be frank more than that I want this
for history I can't wait to look back at
this in 30 years and you know and all
that kind of stuff but but more
importantly I always want all my content
to bring value so just shifting a little
bit the value from a technologists point
of view were you seeing people struggle
or make missteps waste money on tech a
lot of people that are listening to this
or just entrepreneurs who don't
understand I have the great benefit of
sitting literally side by side when I'm
talking shoulder to shoulder with Eric
Kastner my first CTO in 1998 and I
learned a lot like including I mean
these are real crazy stories like I
remember the day he looked at me when I
was looking up a line on Yahoo and he
said go to Google I'm like what's this
and I remember lay up there's a real
story remember landing on google.com
complete white page and like these guys
are never gonna make money there's no
advertising you know like that like it
was just so such a fun time for me but I
learned through osmosis and I think a
lot of entrepreneurs that look like me
didn't get lucky enough to sit next to a
technologist practitioner every day for
three years 18 hours day which led to
being more knowledgeable like I think
when I got into web 2.0 everybody was
stunned by my product knowledge or
understanding back to what you're
bringing up zoom at the depth you know I
think a lot of the entrepreneurs
listening right now don't have the you
and their life so they usually want to
outsource that to India or Poland or
they want to like cut corners or they
overpay let's bring some value like who
what what mistakes are you seeing from a
tech standpoint with people that are
getting into commerce today it's a
loaded question yeah I mean they Paul
like you know common you know it's not
about being right this is about scenario
sharing that may help you know I'm
obsessed with one person getting one
piece of value that might have said I
think a lot of people about to go into
e-commerce and somebody was about to
spend $13,000 on something they don't on
13,000 they don't have and they may hear
you say something that might set them
down a different path yeah I think the
big the big thing right now is there's a
lot of there's a lot of discussion
discussion about like which ecommerce
platform is the right platform right I
mean you mentioned yeah there's Magento
and big commerce and obviously we tend
to lean toward Shopify and more
specifically chop by plus but there's
all kinds of options out there and it's
not necessarily that one platform is the
best at everything we like Shopify
because it's very flexible in the sense
of its kind of just is it this actually
don't know this is it the best price
entry or there are other alternatives I
know where space is starting to play
like again I'm trying to really bring
value to the audiences there do you feel
like it's the most
practical like I was thing about
WordPress and what that meant to content
and I think about the e-commerce
platforms of today you know I'm curious
what your perspective is for the person
that's really trying to start a $50,000
a year ecommerce site where do they go
yeah I've been getting a lot form it
depends right I mean if if the core of
your business is ecommerce and there's
actually kind of the general problem in
the industry right now but if ecommerce
is the focus then Shopify makes a lot of
sense if content is your focus there may
be something like again if you're
starting small something like
Squarespace might make more sense right
do you do use a content platform and
then sprinkle some e-commerce on top or
do you start with a content or an
e-commerce platform and try to build
content around it has been I'm thrown
into robbing is that acute I literally
you don't know this has WordPress
started creating WordPress plugins that
helped for commerce yeah so they glue
commerce is probably the most popular of
those I'm sure you've heard of those who
have I think a lot of people don't even
think of them as WordPress but yeah we
promise
WordPress equivalent so same idea but
it's always it's always this compromise
it's do you care about content or do you
care about e-commerce and one or the
other is going to kind of fall by the
wayside right and so it's definitely I
don't want to say that it's a big
shortcoming of Shopify but just any
e-commerce platform in general could be
Magento or big commerce whatever like
they're not great for content so that
gap that we're trying to really fill
right now is a no compromises solution
where you can make your content and have
proper ecommerce in one platform so
that's a couple people have asked what
sit between Shopify and Shopify plus if
you like ten questions about well the
short answer is price but no there's a
lot more to shop by plus starts at like
two thousand a month as opposed to like
a plaint core Shopify they buy down I
think it's nine dollars and went down
for the starter starter plan so they're
aimed at very very different businesses
Shabtai plus petrale doesn't make sense
and that you're doing like 10 million in
revenue or so maybe maybe just if you
need the features I'm about two thousand
a month you know starting point like
that's you know that's only forty eight
thousand dollars I think for your tech
stack you know even if you're even if
you're
of $3,000,000 it really depends on your
profit right and if you're raising
rapido but like if you're running a
three million dollar business kicking
eight hundred thousand dollars you know
you know like what are your expenses
like it really gets interesting I'm like
where that justifies but nonetheless
respect you could be selling something
that's super high margin and it makes
sense that a million dollars right but
it really comes down to for a lot of
people it's a feature so there's certain
there's certain features that are only
available on plus again they're usually
more targeted at larger businesses like
custom gift card functionality or the
ability to do really customized
discounts and kind of marketing things
that's but if you don't need any of the
plus specific features you can kind of
get away with core for a while and kind
of grow into it which is I think shop
phase plan is to you know start your
small business with us and then they
grow with you and now they're even doing
which is crazy awesome one thing I want
to mention I've been talking about like
the tech side of it just some advice
everybody out there was starting econ or
getting into it or any business frankly
right but I think the thing is people
tend to lean away from what they're good
at or they don't value it as much right
so and it has to do with people brands
of all sizes like they're good at
something they don't really value it and
then they end up trying to do something
completely different
what I'm trying to make here is like
what the entrepreneurs out there they're
trying to start ecommerce you're good at
something there's a reason why you want
to do something right and lean into that
you look at a brand like the hundreds
it's a client of ours like they're they
build street wear culture they're part
of street wear culture you look at their
products you look at the site you look
at the in-store experience it's all
unified and they leaned into that so my
point with this is like find out why
you're starting this thing what matters
to you lean into that and double down on
that and try to stay quarter that
because the bends are the your point
about content and all this stuff that
content or whatever you're putting out
is only gonna resonate with people if it
matters to you and you're doing it for
purpose so on a non-technical level
that's what I would suggest there's yet
so focusing more on as you're as you're
scaling right so the the market in terms
of consumer behavior is heavily being
driven by by Amazon and if you want to
think about
essentially what Shopify is doing is
they call it arming the rebels right
there
you know Amazon has all these resources
to invest into things like logistics in
fulfillments right Amazon Prime you know
all these different capabilities and so
they they win on price they went on
assortment they went on convenience and
if you're a brand and you only have a
finite amount of resources you can't
afford to keep up with all that
innovation because you just don't have
that that that pool of money to invest
shop fight does have the resources for
innovation and not only today are the
resources they're incredibly consistent
and they have a focus on that as an
organization to allow merchants to keep
up with Amazon this is super important
in my perspective on what platform you
choose the reason is right now it may
not look as obvious of how much Amazon's
drive and consumer behavior but in if we
want to fast forward 12 months two years
three four or five years and you're not
keeping up with innovation on things
like payments right or fulfillments you
know simple checkouts then you're going
to be allocating all your resources time
to build that yourself if your platform
you're out you're you're aligning
yourself with isn't doing that and so I
mean everybody's watching this happened
with media with social media this
happened with publishing with WordPress
and Squarespace and all the others like
it's super in
like it's super important to not only
make the right decision but I want to
make sure people aren't crippled by if
you made a decision if you're not a lot
you know as long as you're not too too
locked in you can always pull the
band-aid off
nobody likes changing their tech stack
so why SAS businesses do well you end up
sitting with that business for an extra
year or two then because you're just so
painful to migrate but at the small
scale which a lot of people were
listening on right now you're not gonna
get crushed by making the wrong decision
but to Robby's point making the right
long-term decision that has an impact on
your business
yeah no I want but I want to tie it full
circle to you know why why we acquired
loose infusion so at the same time that
Shopify is incredibly good at
democratizing the tech and enabling you
know a lot of entrepreneurs they also at
the same time eliminate barriers to
entry that previously existed right so
in the 2010s if you could have a site
that could stay up on Black Friday Cyber
Monday
was a value-add to the customer right
you would get that customer's business
and they would come back because they
know that you could withstand all the
different traffic now everyone has a
site that works extremely well and so
what happens is these barriers to entry
that previously existed have gone away
and this is just as true on the
acquisition side with things like
Facebook and Google Ads
and so what happens is well as you have
more competition fueled by venture
capital
you know flooding the market it gets
harder and harder to do what the brands
want to do which is build a sustainable
direct consumer business and so what
what do you do essentially the answer is
you have to start building unique IP you
need to start building unique value
creation and value propositions for your
clients that's actually difficult for
others to copy and if you're just using
Shopify's ecosystem of apps and tech
solutions as they give it to you then
you have the same tech stack as all
these other millions of brands that have
no barriers to entry to copy exactly
what you're doing and so what we would
basically the the bet we were making was
you know even some of the biggest brands
on Shopify for them to scales
sex and they're gonna need to leverage
what Shopify's has the best in the
market which is api's right and build
custom solutions and content and
commerce on top and when you know coming
from Shopify plus when I looked at the
agency ecosystem no one was doing that
they're all building within themes and
they're all leveraging Shopify stools
versus building custom technology
themselves and so that the critical
components have to zoom in and ban and
what they're building was this ability
to leverage the you know the all of
Shopify's investments into innovation
while still being able to build unique
IP around content commerce and other
experiences Zubin coming from that text
back side let's actually come from a
different angle when you and then and
your amazing team have done its best
work text right that's right
what have you seen the common themes
because again I'm trying to bring a lot
of value to the listener sure what has
been the common theme of you seeing
people not be a successful e-commerce as
they as they thought or as you shot
thought they should because you've
created you know in essence the tech
stack is almost like like the restaurant
operating well because I don't have to
get the restaurant people there you have
to be like what's been what's been the
misstep by entrepreneurs small
businesses medium-sized businesses and
big businesses in your mind so yeah so
with with a lot of the companies that
the smaller organizations you can build
them the best tech they can even have
really strong media coming in but then
they hit all sorts of like logistical
issues supply chain issues etc that's on
that side of it right from our
standpoint and so it's really important
to get all those ducks in a row the
other side of from a tech standpoint is
not really knowing what to do with what
we give them so even if we do everything
great if they don't have the right
expertise in-house because at the end of
the day like people hire agencies all
the time we're gonna say just hire
agencies but you have to have some
expertise in-house and so whether it's a
small organization or a large one too
much we're saying look the same way I
talk about social media was that like if
you don't know how to judge the work
you're always gonna be vulnerable yeah
and you gotta have some level of
expertise in-house right like you're I
think but the problem is the braudys are
point about barrier of entry the barrier
to entry is lowered so much for dtc
brands that anybody thinks they can just
open anything and start selling online
but they don't realize that there's a
lot to that business beyond just
spinning up a store and selling the
product and I think that's becoming
abundantly clear especially now with so
much demand for e-commerce right like
we're all seeing it we're all ordering
online things we would have never
ordered and then people that we know in
our lives that never ordered online or
all of a sudden ordering things and
they're realizing the organization's the
companies the brands etc they're [ __ ]
this isn't just a channel for us this
could be the channel the powers
everything including retail business
exactly this is the bit and that's
really what it is it has got this maniac
right now on white XCOM signups because
it's becoming the business the service
is so right the friction is so amazed
lack of friction so insane people the
people are just enjoying the service and
all of a sudden it becomes like when I
when I launched wine text from my dad
when I came up with the idea and they
built it when I when I did Wine Library
I never thought of it as an add-on to
the liquor store I always thought the
liquor store was gonna be the add-on to
that business and I think I think that's
the crossroads a lot of people are gonna
come to to that conclusion in a post
kovin consumer world totally been and
the fact been somebody whose apologizes
who've been get been in here for a
second been by the way everybody was
asking questions on the stream Ben was
on mute because he's a considerate man
and he knows that he's in a windy area
so he didn't want so Ben you know what
what I was curious cuz you've been in
the game so long like I think back to
the biggest myths of my career I was
doing I figured out very early on in
like 1997 that I saw the data on the
carts that weren't completed and I
started contacting people through
whatever information I had and I was
doing OpenCart optimization and
literally it was like a good year or 18
months from then that I even like saw
that hit the ecosystem I was I don't
think I invented it I don't know what
other people were doing but it's always
fun to think back to those early days of
like what I saw that then becomes common
practice from a tech standpoint
what are you seeing right now that you
people are doing that you think is gonna
become of course in a decade just trying
to bring value to the listeners anything
stand out right now yeah well I guess it
depends on the audience right I mean
there's there's so much stuff for me
it's like right now everybody wants to
talk about retail and e-commerce and
then you've got buzzwords like
omni-channel or whatever everything is a
channel right but really it's just it's
all just commerce we need to get away
just free to get away from right and
thence and sell [ __ ] not just food
you're always selling always be selling
then well exactly it's one of these
things where you know we were probably
five ish years away from this and now
we're more like it's literally right now
because of kovat 19 you know I wish the
motivation to get all this stuff done
now is for a different reason but you
know that line is so blurry now right if
you order some products from Walmart and
in their app and then you drive to the
store and they put them in your trunk
was that ecommerce or was that retail it
was neither right it's just commerce I
don't care what you call it
Cobin may actually save Target and other
retailers because I think Walmart's big
enough to like succeed but like there's
a when I think of like like like mid
tier like departments are five below and
other so like I actually think the
curbside is gonna give them a chance
with same-day delivery like in a way
that really is gonna be meaningful
exactly do you predict them is just a
guess because it's too early do you
think curbside is now a standard for
retailers in thirty six months I think
so I'd be very disappointed if when this
all blows over that went away
I mean I think people will get very used
to that I mean it's just a better
experience right it doesn't need to be
about you know oh it's touchless
obviously right now because you know we
want to be social distancing but it's
still a way better experience and then
you can I think the more important part
is you can turn on these retail stores
into more of an experiential
you know shopping place right it's more
like the IKEA model or something like
that where you going and I pry the fryer
up thing that I apologize for
interrupting I'm going on mute people
are mad that I'm interrupting and they
asked if I can go in mute so I'm going
on mute
I'm in a break with Mike side you can
keep going bad no just say you know it
would be great if we had a conversation
about this the other day but you know if
you be walking to you know Best Buy or
something and you're going there to try
out the products and and then when you
you pick out the one that you like and
it's waiting for you at the register and
you they just pop it in your car that's
a much better experience than going into
a store that right now is basically just
aisles and aisles of boxes right I mean
it's not it's not an experience right
now in the same way on the e-commerce
side you know and then we talk about
content and commerce the content so
important because if you're just showing
a boring catalog of stuff you're trying
to compete directly with Amazon like
they've got that game down right you're
not gonna win the I just want to look at
a bunch of stuff but if you're actually
telling the story and you're connecting
with your audience right that that's
something that that Amazon can't compete
with right there that's not there their
goal so you know again I think you're
gonna see that experience change online
and I think it's I think it's thank you
so yeah I think that it's interesting
it's related also to driving sustainable
growth in the dot-com I think there's
been a lot of assumptions made around
what the value is of d2c you know and
and we you know we've seen this in terms
of if you just look at where you know
the majority of brands allocate
resources on a dvc operation and they
allocate it to the acquisition they sell
the product and then there's you know
that's that's the majority of their
their resource allocation and they think
the value creation for the customer is
in the product alone and then you know
if you're in food and Bev you you don't
see even the value in T to see because
you can get that on Amazon what we've
proven what we figured out was that
that's just that's just sort of a broken
understanding it's built on a lot of
sort of lot of assumptions there's tons
of ways whether it's you know delivery
or SMS like Gary's been able to break
down with us there's all these different
areas to create value for your customer
and not only our brands
ownership brands be aware of that they
actually the shift towards that because
everyone else has figured out the value
creation on acquisition and you know
having easy you know having a PP in a
shop buy store and so we're I think
where we see a lot of problems with
sustainability and loyalty and lifetime
value is there's been no no resources or
time spent on figuring out what is the
actual value creation we want to deliver
over the lifecycle of a customer at
every point post purchase as well and
and so I think there's a lot of
connections there where people just have
certain assumptions on how DTC works
what retail does what Amazon does and
they've never even experimented and or
understood really what their consumers
were we're looking for I think there's a
really important point for those of you
at home in terms of what Robbie's
talking about and then like to kind of
that as Gary was mentioning translating
what I said the translate a little bit
of what Robbie just mentioned right now
what we've realized and that apply is
kind of to all brands turning it any
size is that it's not about being right
right every time it's about realizing
the right is not a binary concept it's
not yes or no it's like you have these
goals you want to get to these goals
it's not only when you cross that line
were you successful and really what
we've realized is that being almost
right most of the time it's better than
being precisely right occasionally and
so we apply that to everything we do as
Robbie's talking about and we were
mentioning earlier I was talking about
like full funnel growth and whatnot what
it really means is that we try to find
right for our clients as you should try
to find right with everything you do and
and not be feel them know what's right
or that you know what's right but you
got to get into it and you got to test
this stuff and so whether it's tact
whether it's messaging it's creative its
media everything you're doing you've got
to test the [ __ ] out of it in order to
find out like what's the best thing for
your brand what's the best thing for you
and then ultimately for your consumers
what do they care about in terms of your
brand you're going to talk about all
these things about this widget that you
have and why it's so great and then
realize that the reason why they want it
is because it's pink and that's the only
reason they want it so [ __ ] down on
the fact that it's pink and build your
entire narrative around that
I think that just test and iterate as
much as you can and that's where you'll
really actually find like those unicorn
opportunities to massively scale and I'm
just gonna say one one thing on that to
it
Oh a word or buzzword that kind of irks
me is best practices they're important
right no doubt it's a great starting
point but that's literally all that it
is like best practices or where you can
maybe get an idea where to start testing
but this idea that I don't need to test
because I'm following all the best
practices and like Amazon already
figured this out for me total [ __ ]
right it might work for Amazon it
doesn't mean that it's going to work for
you so really that that testing and
using a tech stack that allows you to
easily test is kind of one of the most
important things that you can do yeah
Gary us at the beginning you know how to
describe inter Commerce I think this
sets up so maybe the most important
point which is we're talking about all
these things and the observation we've
had is no one's built the right
infrastructure for it right so we we've
built the infrastructure of all these
DTC brands or modern-day brands around
acquisition we've built cultures around
it
we built measure measurement systems
around it and and so you know to create
a system to operate at a level of
experimentation across the full funnel
requires not having constraints right so
some of those constraints are technology
some of them are how you actually or you
know organize your your your people part
of it is your measurement systems and I
would say even you know the most
sophisticated brands we've come across
the ones get the praise in the headlines
aren't structured in a way to take
advantage of all the things that were
talking about and so the infrastructures
broken and it was built on the back of
where value is created the 2010s right
which was the gold rush of paid media
that now that the value creation you
know where values credit now has shifted
it's a moving target these
infrastructures haven't adapted and
they're not built to now capture it and
so I think the good news for the
audience whether you're a fortune 100
executive whether you're an entrepreneur
or you know you
whether you're already one of these
brands is it's a level playing field I
don't think the fortune 100 are behind I
don't think the DC brands you know are
behind cuz they're running a media
everyone's starting the same you know
they're showing that the same race
because it's a new game that requires a
new way of thinking about growth and no
one from our observation and we talked
to hundreds of brands have built the
infrastructure to be able to do it all
right
that was about as difficult of a task
and there was really good stuff coming
out but unfortunately I almost died
all right so let's wrap this up because
I gotta get to my next meeting
pretty much I'm really excited I hope
the audience got some value out of that
I really tried to steer the conversation
into you know it's always tough when we
meet when we launch a new company we did
it with Sasha we did about other things
we've been excited me and Robbie been
sitting on this for two plus years going
back to sabir and some of the great
people on our team Angela and acts on
others we've been sitting on this for a
very very long time you know obviously
we did some commerce capabilities inside
of vaynermedia as a division but to be a
standalone company to have Vayner
commerce comm please everybody who's
listening right now if you have any
commerce needs or anybody that you know
does please go check out banner commerce
comm fill out the forms I think the team
did an incredible job I went on it's
probably the best Manor x company's
website at this point on if something
issue launched a good job on that team I
think I think there's a I think there's
a lot of opportunity in this space
forget about Vayner commerce and what
we're bringing to the table I think
anybody who's listening if you do not
realize how much opportunity there is to
sell stuff on the internet and how early
we are whether you know whether you
believe the reports or I think zoom and
Ben keep me honest you're Robby 14 15
percent of all commerce now is
e-commerce you know was 12 forever I
think we all probably agree that we'll
see a bigger spike and probably have
zoomed up to three four years in advance
because of kovat the opportunity for so
many entrepreneurs and more importantly
if you're a big company if you own a
store if you if you're listening right
now and you own a store and your store
or stores does five million a year in
revenue top-line if you are not
seriously
getting serious about launching an
e-commerce not the [ __ ] that you
check the box in 2002 and you have one
and it's a still garbage [ __ ] static
picture like some dog [ __ ] I mean like
really really getting focused about
e-commerce during this time get yourself
educated check out things like 2:00 p.m.
you know my buddy web Smith to PML calm
like that's a good source Robbie what do
I know that's a newsletter that we
respect is there any other sources I
mean there's Google you can look up [ __ ]
is there any other sources I know you
we're planning on putting out a good
amount of content I just really want to
help this community get serious about it
any other things stand out to you Robbie
from a Content standpoint I know you
follow all this [ __ ] no I think I think
to be I'm scared I think we're gonna
work to fill a void that that's there
and then you know I think we could
probably put together a Twitter list of
people to follow and different things
yeah why don't we why don't we why don't
you do that what are you on leave is it
a pain or Commerce that's what I handle
everybody who's interested in us go
check out Vayner commerce on Twitter
it's fainter Commerce one-word no-spaces
all that banner commerce Robbie team do
me a favor put out show a little love to
the community that you guys grew up in
put out some handles of people that
people should know about as well and so
uh any last parting shots then zoom in
Robbie no this is great let's do it
again
thanks it's awesome thank you these
listening and watching I'm gonna have a
bunch of really interesting people on
the podcast coffee and commerce kind of
little sub brand that I'm gonna play
under hopefully five or six meaningful
interviews over the next two weeks that
you can learn from this kind of launches
it you kind of become aware of the
characters I really appreciated the love
that Ben zuman and Robbie got in the
comment section on the live streams
really very kind words I hope you guys
are able to go look back and see the
nice words also thanks guys yeah the
mute session I went through was a great
moment of silence yeah thank you for
everybody listening I hope you have a
wonderful day I hope we've inspired some
new thoughts or some hypotheses that you
can double click into have a great day
and and Vayner commerce is here a big
day I
would argue the company I probably
should have started my world with given
that I had credibility in commerce in
2009 when I started vaynermedia but
we've gotten here eventually and we're
excited use a bunch of good work and if
you need any help please go to boehner
commerce comm fill out the forum's check
us out I think we're even hiring Robby I
saw there's a section of that people
like so lot of cool stuff there thank
you everyone
think he's ooh but then Robby talk to
you soon bye bye everyone
like I see